I think actually one of the still most
alive arguments is what I call in the
appendix the the moral argument the the
belief that morality needs God's will to
ground it moral truths are somewhat
mysterious you know I keep talking about
you know the pushback from the worldís
and you know empirical evidence but
moral truths are seemed to be of a
different nature from that so that it's
not it's not a when one saying looks
slavery is wrong we're not saying we've
decided that slavery is wrong or that
you know in my particular society we've
outlawed slavery were take even a strong
you know genocide is wrong I think all
of us believe this very strongly I think
everybody I'm talking to and at least
one big think believes this very very
strong like how do how do we justify
this belief if you can do philosophers
love thought experiments you know if in
fact you know Adolf Hitler had triumphed
it had and and and had gone forth with
his his plan of exterminating all the
undesirables you know finished with the
Jews and the gypsies and the gays and
gone on to the Slavs and you know he had
a whole agenda a whole plan of who was
going to be wiped out but say it would
it had taken place and our world was
that way it was a world in which one
believed this was a very good thing that
all these undesirables had been wiped
out yet one could stay that would be an
immoral world that bet that that is a
moral monstrosity to consider it so
these these there's something a little
mysterious about these statements they
don't seem to have an empirical
grounding they seem to be super
empirical trance
and well if their transcendence don't
they need a transcendent force a
transcendent will that impose them and
so that I think has you know a certain
cogent see to it them is the
mysteriousness
of moral truths if you believe in them
you could say okay they don't really
exist I mean it really is a matter of
sociology and psychology but if you
really do believe no even had Hitler
triumphed it is still true that genocide
is wrong and that that would be a
morally heinous world where does that
come from how do I know this if not
because it comes from God so I hope that
I've now put even strong atheists into a
state of oh well yes tell us please how
do we get out of this and you know I do
analyze that argument in the appendix do
you want it quickly yes I mean there are
two parts to it really one is and this
to me is an extremely strong argument
there's one part is to say religion
doesn't help at all there's a mystery
here but theology theism religion
doesn't answer it at all and then the
second part which is the harder part is
to say well then how do we answer it and
I don't know if I can I mean that's
moral philosophy I can give you a very
quick rundown of how I think you ground
it but more importantly I think is the
destructive argument that religion
doesn't help at all in the argument
really is so ancient the core of the
argument is so ancient it goes all the
way back to Plato my first love and his
dialogue the Euthyphro and where he
considers you know could it be the case
that what makes something good is that
the gods or you know in our case
God loves it and God wants us to do it
because God loves it so is to put it
more in terms not have a naught naught
but a nod I mean ought we to
give charity because God wants us to or
is there some independent reason well
let's say it's only you know because God
wants us to and then the next question
is what does God want us to does God
have a reason for wanting us to be
charitable to take care of me
those who can take care of themselves
either God does or God doesn't it's just
logic if God has a reason then there's a
reason independent of God and whatever
God's reason is we should figure it out
for ourselves there is a reason and God
doesn't really Gram morality at all God
wants us to give charity because it's
the right thing to do there's a reason
why it's the right thing to do and
that's what makes it the right thing to
do God's just going along for the ride
God's not offering anything here or God
has no reason at all he might have
flipped it he might have said you know
said thou shalt commit genocide and thou
shalt never give charity it's completely
arbitrary and there are no grounds
independent of God's will I mean he
might have said thou shalt wear your
pants backwards on Friday afternoon is
that does that help us at all answer our
moral quandary zwo is it about moral
truths that make them true this
arbitrary whim of a God that you can't
even say is moral because there's no
morality independent of him so God is
either redundant or or or on you know or
we don't get morality so it's you know
it's either one or the other
God doesn't help I think that's a
knockdown argument I think that it's it
really shows that whatever moral
knowledge we have and whatever moral
progress were make in our knowledge or
whatever knowledge we make it or
whatever progress we make in our moral
knowledge it's not coming really from
religion it's coming from the very hard
work really of moral philosophy of
trying to ground our moral reasonings
and thinkers like
Plato and Aristotle and Kant and in our
own day my own dissertation adviser Tom
Nagel was Princeton when I worked with
him is now at NYU and his wonderful book
the possibility of altruism have helped
us to see that we certain attitudes that
we already have attitudes about our own
lives
moral logically compel us to broaden our
sense of of the interests we take in
others as long as we experience any such
emotions as moral outrage when people
step on our own interest as soon as we
do that we're on the road if we look at
our attitudes consistently and work out
the logical implications we're on the
road to moral progress moral
understanding so those are the two
halves of that of that argument